europe's regulators continue to take on
big tech
apple has become the fourth us tech
giant to be hit by such probes
the german federal card cartel office
says a key focus of the investigation
will be the operation of the app store
it says in many cases
it empowers apple to have an influence
on the business activities of third
parties
the anti-trust authority recently opened
similar investigations
against amazon google and facebook under
a new law
andreas munt is the president of the
federal cartel office here in germany
welcome to the program how easy is it to
change the competitive dynamic
now years after apple was apparently
allowed to accumulate all this market
power
yeah i mean of course it's a complex
task i mean we are in the digital
economy for a couple of years already
and we are very happy that we have have
obtained some new regulation over here
in germany
that came into force at the beginning of
2021
and we try now to make use of these new
tools and new instruments
with regards to to the tech giants it
will remain
complex but on the other hand i do
believe that with the new instruments
um our life will might get somewhat
easier
to tackle the big tech companies
with regard to their competitive
behavior
so regulatory instruments have improved
if i understand what you're saying but
if you do find that apple's ecosystem of
digital products across
across markets is anti-competitive what
will you do
well i think this is really the first
step now
the new regulation has a two-step
approach the first step and this is the
one we are taking now
is to designate apple to have a
paramount significance
for for competition across markets once
apple is designated that way or any
other company
it is easier to prohibit certain
dues or to to to to
enforce certain do's and don'ts against
uh against the company
um what we will try to do with all the
tech giants
is that we try to identify
anti-competitive behavior
or maybe even more important
anti-competitive
elements in the business case of these
companies
and to bring that to an end because we
think then markets might be contestable
again and we can protect consumers of
course
from anti-competitive behavior of these
companies
mr sounds a little bit like putting the
genie back into
the bottle is that at all possible
i firmly believe it is i mean if you
look if you look into the past and see
what competition agencies have already
done
in this area then i think it is also
it is very convincing in a way i mean
think of the
proceeding that we have had here against
amazon back in 2019
and since 2019
amazon has to give a reason for
termination contracts
with the sellers they have
they cannot do that from one day to
another
there must be a certain delay in in
ending the contract
um sellers and that is very important
have the right
uh for civil claims here in germany
before german courts
and not before luxembourg any uh
luxembourg calls anymore
and even even more important maybe
amazon is liable towards the seller so
you see we can really change terms and
conditions of these companies
and give more rights to those
who have to work with these companies
all think of the
the facebook case that we are hopefully
bringing to a good end with the help of
the courts
where we have asked facebook foreign
internal divestiture of the data they
hold
um which has a huge impact maybe on the
dominance of facebook
so i do believe there are many means
with regard to
competition law and regulation that we
have right now
and if we make good use of it um it's
maybe
it's maybe not that far-reaching than
than you said
uh putting the genie back into the
bottle it's
just establishing a healthy competition
environment in this area
we have to start somewhere andreas mont
is the president of the federal cartel
office
thank you so much for your time today
thank you very much